religious beliefs in America are
changing a recent Pew Research Center
survey found 65 percent of American
adults describe themselves as Christians
but that is down 12 percent over just
the past decade 26 percent identify as
atheist agnostic or nothing in
particular that's up from just 17
percent in 2009 Cardinal Timothy Dolan
is the Roman Catholic Archbishop of New
York and his new book is who do you say
I am daily reflections on the Bible the
Saints and the answer that is Christ he
writes about the importance of God and
faith in our everyday lives and cardinal
Dolan joins us first on CBS this morning
Cardinal welcome Guardians thank you to
have got me to good because I'm usually
here at Christmas so I'm in the spirit
already very good very good so getting
in a spirit for this segment I looked at
the devotional for this very day and it
is the first line is becoming more and
more clear that our society is looking
down on religion and on that point I
think indisputably one of the reasons
why is people look at the sex abuse
scandal uh-huh that the Catholic Church
has been plunged into and they wonder
and I say this is somebody who has three
generations of Catholics in New York
it's topped with my generation I ask you
as a journalist but also as somebody
with that lineage how could this have
happened and why the Catholic Church in
not Islam or Judaism or evangelical
Christianity why did this scandal engulf
your church in particular well sometimes
we wonder that ourselves Tony because as
a matter of fact it has engulfed all
faiths all levels of society and culture
it's a cultural societal problem it's
laser beamed on us because rightly
people expect more of the church and
when the church Falls and commits this
kind of nauseating sin it's going to
bring more attention to it and it should
because not only or have we in the past
committed these sins were hypocritical
because we're the ones that have
preached against it and it just upsets
people that the very ones that are
preaching against it have been guilty of
it you said at one point your own mother
was was embarrassed to be oh my lord my
own mom who's in a beautiful assisted
living out in Washington Missouri she
said I'm not going down to the
dining room most of the time she said I
like going there because they're asking
about you you son who's a priest but so
what did you say your mother did you say
I said mom I'm embarrassed too
we're all embarrassed that out of the
out of this embarrassment I trust is
going to come renewal hope and reform
and I think it is so Cardinal I mean
this is decades long there is definitely
a reckoning in society you're absolutely
right about that but but at all levels
and all layers all industries but at the
same time the Catholic Church is a
decade's long scandal thousands of
victims billions of dollars in payments
is it not categorically different it's
set aside and apart and and what changes
were made to fix what the problems were
so that people who are still interested
thinking about the next generation will
come back well thanks for reminding us
that there have been changes and those
changes started in 2002 with what we
call the Dallas Charter which you all
and journalists have done a very good
job of reporting on so there there was a
tsunami shift in 2002 that the church
said hey you know what we've been an
example of what not to do in the past
now we need to be an example of what to
do and the past 17 18 years there would
be tangible verifiable data that we are
ahead of this and that we cleaned up our
act you reported on it that what about
three weeks ago Judge Barbara Jones and
acclaimed federal judge that I had asked
a year ago I said would you please my
people still don't seem to believe us
that we have reformed and cleaned this
up would you do a scrupulous study of
all the procedures that we've done in
the Archdiocese of New York here's the
key no records are barred and report
back in a year and she did and she said
I give the Archdiocese of New York and a
they have kept their promises so boy it
was bad in the past but I think now I
hope were a sign of reform and the way
to handle this you got an a but
Monsignor John paddock in your arch dies
was accused earlier as you know of
molesting at least five boys for more
than a decade the allegations continued
he stepped down but he was allowed to
continue working y-yeah can you tell us
about him and my roots that was about
ten years ago an accusation came in
against Monsignor paddocks so that's
probably the one you met
and that he was allowed to stay in so by
what the Charter tells us to do we hand
it over to the police this year he was
accused of all that's that's really nice
the allegations that's recent but the
first one we looked the DA looked into
forensic outside investigators looked
into and it went to the lay review board
to say this charge is not credible so he
was allowed back in you're right of late
other accusations came in but there's a
lot of people accused but we look for
there has to be some type of
substantiation that having been said we
finally said John this is not good
there's accusations coming in yes we
have to look for substantiation in the
meantime you need to step aside what
we've promised is that no priest against
whom there's been a substantiate an
allegation can ever again serve in
ministry are you saying that are you
still supporting patek financially yes
we are yeah yeah he's still innocent
until proven guilty since the statute of
limitations has been lifted
how many more lawsuits have been filed
oh there's a lot now we had already
entered into the Independent
reconciliation and compensation program
that's four years old that has been
praised by victims and and the public
alike and in that there were about 350
victims that came forward and reported
as a sense of resolution and finality
and we were grateful to the church we're
where I'm concerned about the time
because I'm curious to get your thoughts
on the group of Catholic Bishops that
decided or advocating for men Oh at the
seminary what do you think about that
well look you know this was what we call
a synod was an anything-goes roundtable
and conversation there's been scented
since the mid 60's every three years
Pope Francis sort of opened him up a bit
this was a regional Synod gale
in the Amazon because he's worried about
the environmental the poverty do you
think it's a good idea for priests to
have the option of marrying I'm glad
they brought it up I'm glad they talked
about it we act like it's a big secret
but heck my barber asks me why priests
can how do you feel yeah would you want
to get would you like there to be a mrs.
Dolan you
look I would love to be married and have
kids but you know what Pope Paul the
sixth said you shouldn't be a celibate
if you don't want to be married and have
kids celibates are different than
bachelors celibates want to be a father
and want to be a spouse and they
transfer it to their allegiance to the
church which is their family so a desire
for to be a father and a husband is a
healthy normal beautiful thing and I've
got it but do I regret not being married
well I might miss it but right now
celibacy I find to be extraordinarily
rewarding and liberating all right does
that help thank you say the name of the
book for every day of the year we have
daily reflections on the Bible the
Saints in the answer that normal is fine
for being with us